[Music]
so today i'm gonna go to the grocery
store for the first time in over two
years and i'm gonna pick up some
groceries with a 50
budget the price of food is rising
across the world and it's getting really
hard to make ends meet for a lot of us
especially those with families to feed a
lot of my favorite foods are just not as
accessible anymore but of course my
family still needs to eat and i want to
do my best to meet my family's
nutritional needs with a bit of extra
planning on my part so for context 50
canadian is about 38 to 39 usd and i'm
going to be attempting to feed my family
of four so my goal today is to really
focus on getting a few things in the
following categories um protein produce
and grains and i also want to try to
leave a little bit of wiggle room for
like one or two maybe
kind of fun non-essential foods because
let's be real i still have to enjoy my
week of food so normally i buy all my
groceries online using grocery delivery
apps and i've actually been shopping
this way
since well before the pandemic when i
became a mom because you know i just
found that like that one hour or two
going to the grocery store became just
so much more valuable to me and i just i
would rather use that time to spend time
with my family or get something else
done around the house but i literally
have not been in this grocery store
where i used to go all the time since
like well before march 2020 so
it's going to be interesting to see how
the experience has changed now i do
actually find that i probably save a lot
of money shopping on kind of grocery
apps because you know i find that the
apps will feed you all of your
essentials or all of your like go-to
items so i don't feel like i'm tempted
by all the marketing of all the
different new products that are often
more expensive that i actually see
visually when i go to the store this way
i'm really only buying the things that i
know that i need because they are on my
grocery list and not just looking pretty
at the end of the aisle okay so let's go
in and we are shooting on our iphone
right now because we want to make sure
we're a little more discreet
so for produce options i like to have
something that i can do either cooked or
served raw if you want to do like salads
or just snacking so
let's see what we can get for a good
price
so carrots are a great option because i
can serve them cooked for my kiddos and
also raw for salads and they're only
about 30 cents per hundred grams so a
really great option so for another raw
veg cabbage is awesome it's so cheap
this cabbage head will literally be like
so we love it cooked and we also love it
sloths
okay so generally speaking root
vegetables are great nutritious bag for
your buck potatoes are a staple in my
house my kids love them pretty much
anyway so we're gonna pick up a few for
the whole pin
bananas are pretty much always
inexpensive all year round which we love
um they're technically never in season
here in canada but they're always in
season because we love them we always
have at least a big bunch of bananas at
the ready to eat for every week bonus
points for the marble sticker that
always goes over well with kids and men
inevitable
there are so many different breads on
the market now um what i always look for
are the words full grain in the
ingredient list and often the store
bakeries version is one of the cheapest
so that's we're getting today
on just fifty dollars i feel like it's
gonna be a week of vegetarian eats just
to save some cash but if i were to
splurge on some kind of meat or poultry
i'd go for a full piece of poultry like
a whole chicken rather than the
individual pieces that have already been
butchered the bones out and the skin off
you can always do this work at home and
it's going to save you so much cash
oh my gosh
i have not had viva puffs
since i was a little girl my grandmother
used to keep these in the freezer and
they were like one of the most exciting
things to get to go over to grandma's
house to have a frozen
pizza pop
how much are they
two for six bucks
so hot tip if you didn't know this
already this is going to change your
shopping life but a lot of different
brands have different size and shape
containers which can make it very
confusing and difficult to compare
prices so you want to actually look more
carefully at the price per hundred grams
that's going to help you compare apples
to apples and oranges to oranges and
help you find the best price no matter
what size the container is
so this one is a dollar per hundred
grams the mixed nuts is 250 per hundred
grams and if you go with the larger
container we're looking at just 54 cents
per hundred grams so it seems like it's
a no-brainer so there's no question that
you can save a lot of money just buying
your pulses like your beans and legumes
dry
but you also have to factor in whether
or not it's realistic for you to do that
and i just know myself i'm never gonna
think ahead and take the time to soak or
cook those beans and lentils ahead of
time when i'm having to really
soak the beans and cook the beans for a
long period of time so i always keep a
few cans of beans and lentils in my
pantry which i just feel is a lot better
use of my money than to buy dried and
let it collect dust
[Music]
buying a big sack of rice like this is a
great way to save money but i don't have
the budget for like 30 of rice today so
i'm gonna save that for another time but
it is a great little tip even when
tomatoes are in season here nothing
beats the flavor of canned
mayonnaise is not on my shopping list
because you know it sucks
you can totally splurge and get whole
grain pasta and yes you will get a
little bit more fiber but at the end of
the day it's always way more expensive
and the fiber difference is honestly
negligible we're talking about four
grams of fiber versus six
just add a vegetable
see if these ones
those are my favorites those are my
favorites
fruit by the foot starburst all pink
i thought they got rid of donkeys in
canada i thought they do too but here we
are reunited at last it seems like it's
meant to be other than the fact that
it's six bucks or you can get a single
dunkaroo for two bucks
just one i know i know a lot of
influencers like to hate on peanut
butter and almond butter has such a
health halo but the fact is peanuts
actually have the highest amount of
protein of most of the nuts out there on
the market today so peanut butter is
actually a really really great option if
you're on a budget
[Applause]
the canadian in me
is dying to taste it
oats are the ultimate cheap and cheerful
breakfast a bag of oats will go so much
further than any of those box cereals
will
if your family drinks milk like mine
does the four liter bagged version comes
in at half the price as the two-liter
carton so it's a great deal
tell me you're canadian without saying
you're canadian i'm sorry i don't speak
canadian let me get someone over here
mike we have a canadian brown white it
actually doesn't matter that's just the
breed of the hen so get whatever egg is
within your bucket
entering the freezer i'll
didn't bring my parka
this thing for me
so for throwing veg into casseroles or
pastas or stir-fries or smoothies frozen
is the way to go so if you compare
frozen greens to fresh you're looking at
about four dollars per hundred grams for
the fresh
versus
versus 90 cents per hundred grams for
the frozen such a better deal and
because they're in the freezer they last
longer so nothing goes to waste
i feel like if i lived in california i
could get some really great deals on
fresh berries but even when they're in
season here in canada frozen tends to be
a greater bang for your buck frozen
produce is actually often more
nutritious than fresh because it's been
flash frozen at the peak of perfection
so it locks in those nutrients so that
they're not lost in transit
so i did promise myself that i would
make room in my budget for something
that i was like really excited about
that maybe isn't exactly essential
and that of course is gonna be ice cream
[Applause]
now chapman's is the least expensive at
3.99 for a container
but i don't love it so i'm not sure what
the point is on me spending four bucks
on something that i'm not gonna be
jazzed about eating
so
let's take a look at another alternative
that's maybe a little more expensive but
i'm a little more excited about
i don't know what elk crossing is but it
sounds pretty canadian
and that's my style
it's going to be the most canadian
grocery haul you've ever seen americans
this is what's up
you guys know i'm obsessed with hemp
hearts and chia and flax as really great
nutritious sprinkles
but we brand is also a really great
inexpensive source of protein and fiber
and b vitamins so it's great for adding
into smoothies or putting on your
oatmeal yogurt or whipping up into
pancakes or other baked goods
ultimately i ended up a bit over budget
which i think just goes to show how
challenging these times really are i
know that for a lot of you that extra
eight dollars would just not be possible
so i do acknowledge my privilege in this
but if you're in a season of life or
maybe you're relying on more processed
foods or you can't eat as many
vegetables as you'd like have some
empathy for yourself know that you are
doing an amazing job because i used all
the tools in my dietitian toolbox and
ultimately it was clearly very tough so
these are not easy times 58 bucks not
bad and we've got a few selections each
of our grains our produce and our
protein so i want to give you guys some
ideas on what i could do with this haul
we can do some oatmeal with wheat bran
in there for some extra fiber made with
our milk add in some peanut butter and
lots of fruit on top super simple
breakfast we've got some scrambled eggs
some peanut butter toast and a banana on
the side we could do a smoothie with our
milk fruit nut butter and a little wheat
bran you can do a pasta with our white
beans and tomatoes some spinach and
carrots here we can do a peanut sauce
cold noodle salad with cabbage carrots
and some peanuts on top add in a few
spices and we can do baked beans on
toast if you've got mayo or yogurt in
the fridge we could do a egg salad
sandwich with a little cabbage slaw on
top well i wouldn't do that but
some of you might and we can do a quick
little slaw with some hard-boiled eggs
some beans and some nuts on top and a
perfectly complete meal just as is well
i call that a success i mean
we didn't quite meet the 50
goal post but i'd say the ice cream
splurge was worth it i would love to
hear some of your money saving grocery
tips and hacks in the comments below and
if you liked this video please be sure
to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below if you'd like to see more
fun vlogs like this subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]